mit Bildern die um die Welt gehen unsere
Portal paul ronsheimer hat sie
mitgebracht mit einer von der Front die
Toten russischen Soldaten die liegen
noch auf der Straße in der von
ukrainischen Soldaten befreiten statt
Liman in der Region Donetsk im
Ortsschild wird die ukrainische Flagge
im Herbstwind für die Ukraine ist es
viel mehr als nur die Einnahme einer
weiteren Stadt sie ist ein Symbol Liman
die erste Stadt die nach dem illegalen
Referendum und Putins Drohungen wieder
in ukrainischer Hand ist
es sind die Spuren einer heftigen
Schlacht tote Russen Pflastern die
Straße nach lümmern das seit fünf
Monaten von Russen besetzte Gebiet wurde
nun wieder zurückerobert die Einwohner
von luman sind endlich wieder in ihrer
Ukraine Einwohner wie sie die 70-Jährige
Ekaterina ist so froh dass die
ukrainische Armee sie befreit hat doch
die Spuren der russenherrschaft sind
auch ihr ins Gesicht geschrieben
es war schrecklich
beängstigend furchterregend
ich möchte nur sagen
ich wurde in der Ukraine geboren und
alle meine Verwandten sind aus der
Ukraine
schaut mir zu
filmt das niemals
[Musik]
ich küsse mein Ukraine
es ist mein Land
es sind nur wenige Einwohner hier
geblieben in ihrem Limahl sie sind sich
sicher die Russen die kommen nicht
wieder ich sage es Ihnen Sie werden
nicht zurückkommen sie können uns
beschießen sie können uns töten aber sie
werden nicht zurückkommen wenn sie
bleiben wollten wären sie geblieben aber
sie sind zweimal weggelaufen wie
Feiglinge der Weg nach Lühmann das
Schlachtfeld vor der Stadt es sieht so
aus als wären die Russen von dem Angriff
komplett überrascht worden Medikamente
Nahrungsmittel und Kleidung liegen
verteilt am Wegesrand nur wenige Stunden
nach der Schlacht um Lühmann erreicht
Bild vizepoll-ronsheimer die befreite
Stadt hinter mir sieht man Dutzende
Leichen die immer noch in dieser Straße
liegen am Wald um die Soldaten herum
sieht man Minen die sehr wahrscheinlich
auch hier überall im Wald angelegt
wurden die ukrainische Armee geht davon
aus dass es immer noch sehr sehr
gefährlich ist sich hier in der Region
zu bewegen es ist ihr Land das Land der
Ukraine dass sie sich nun Stück für
Stück zurückholen aus der Geiselhaft der
Russen das den Ukrainern dieser Sieg
gelungen ist ist ein Zeichen an die
ganze Welt die Einnahme von Liman ist
ein großer Sieg für die Ukraine und die
ukrainische Armee will damit auch ein
Zeichen senden an die Welt dass sie
imstande sind hier weitere Regionen
weitere Städte weitere Dörfer
zurückzugewinnen auch wenn die Stadt
Menschen leer wirkt der Krieg ist hier
überall zu hören Artillerie Feuer
erklingt an jeder Ecke aus weiter Ferne
denn es geht weiter für die ukrainische
Armee weiter in die Gebiete die von
Russland illegal annektiert wurden das
Ziel der Ukraine alle von Russen
besetzten Gebiete zurückzugewinnen
inklusive der Krim
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und mir zugeschaltet aus der Ukraine ist
das Bild Vize Paul ronsheimer Paul
beschreib uns einmal die Situation
aktuell in Liman und gleichzeitig eine
Frage die dir wie ich gesehen habe auch
viel in den sozialen Medien gestellt
wurde wie war es für dich an den Toten
russischen Soldaten vorbei zu fahren was
ging dir dadurch den Kopf
Patricia das ist etwas an dass man sich
auch als Reporter hier nicht gewöhnen
kann wir kamen nach Liman in diese
Straße haben dort dann die zerschossenen
Autos gesehen und dort dann überall die
russischen Soldaten die Leichen und ich
war dort mit einem Offizier der
ukrainischen Armee den ich dort in
dieser Straße getroffen habe und wir
haben darüber gesprochen was er durch
den Kopf geht wenn man diese Leichen
sieht und er sagte zu mir schauen ihre
Gesichter warum sind sie hierher
gekommen und das ist genau die Frage die
sich viele Ukrainer Stellen in diesen
Stunden in diesen Tagen denn es kommen
immer mehr Russen hierher weitere Russen
hunderttausende die eingezogen werden
und die Region rund um Liman da wird
gerade weiter gekämpft die ukrainische
Armee versucht dort weiter vorzustoßen
weitere Städte und Dörfer
zurückzugewinnen und das ist ein das
Spiel gegen die Zeit denn die Russen
wollen
Personal neues Gerät hier reinschaffen
und bevor das funktioniert wollen die
Ukraine so viele Gebiete wie möglich
zurückerobern wie kommt denn die her
Offensive im Südosten weiterhin voran
zuletzt konnte man ja viele Erfolge
vermelden wie etwa auch in lümern
insbesondere im Süden also in der Region
das ist eine weitere Region die illegal
annektiert werden soll wo es die
illegalen Referenten gab auch dort kommt
die ukrainische Armee voran ist
allerdings rund 70 Kilometer immer noch
entfernt von der großstadtresson das
heißt das ist dort ein langer heftiger
Kampf und das heißt dass dort auch
professionellere russische Truppen sind
also diejenigen zum Beispiel Wagner
Spezialeinheiten und weitere
russeneinheiten die diese Stadt
unbedingt verteidigen wollen sie haben
jetzt großen Druck aus Russland vom
Regime vom von der Bevölkerung sozusagen
das jetzt nicht weitere Niederlagen hier
passieren wir müssen Paul über etwas
sprechendes für große Entrüstung und
Kopfschütteln sorgt an diesem Morgen der
reichste Mann der Welt Elon Musk der hat
jetzt ein wirklichen Friedensplan
vorgelegt und diesmal muss man sagen da
übernimmt er einfach eins zu eins die
Kreml Propaganda lass uns gemeinsam auf
das schauen was er auf Twitter schreibt
ein vier Punkteplan und will dass seine
Follower darüber abstimmen er will eine
Wiederholung der Wahlen in den
annektierten Regionen unter unaufsicht
schreibt er und Russland würde dann die
Ukraine verlassen wenn dies der Wille
des Volkes ist Punkt zwei sagt er die
Krim die gehöre formell zu Russland und
die Ukraine bleiben neutral so schreibt
er und maskügt hinzu dass ein möglicher
wenn auch unwahrscheinliche Ausgang
dieses Konfliktes ein Atomkrieg sei
darauf weist er also hinter Faktor
fordert Maske also eine Kapitulation der
Ukraine und schauen wir auf das was
selensky ukraines Präsident darauf
antwortet Paul denn er ruft selbst eine
Follower zur Abstimmung auf und fragt
welchen Elon Musk magst du mehr einer
der die Ukraine unterstützt oder einer
der Russland unterstützt und in weniger
ist einer Stunde Stimmen mehr als
400.000 Twitter User über silenskys
Frage ab das Ergebnis eindeutig 90
Prozent für einen mask der die Ukraine
unterstützt und das sind noch nicht alle
Reaktionen blicken wir ganz schnell noch
auf die von Litauens Präsidenten aus
jeder denn auch der schaltet sich ein
und versucht das Ganze Paul zu
übersetzen in Tesla Sprache für mask und
sagt lieber Elon Musk wenn jemand
versucht die Reifen ihres Teslas zu
stehlen macht das denjenigen wieder zum
rechtmäßigen Besitzer des Autos noch der
Reifen also eine Abstimmung zu einem
friedensszenario er kassiert eine totale
Klatsche einmal kurz der Blick noch
drauf mehr als 60 Prozent der User
stimmten übrigens für nein bei der
Abstimmung von Elon Musk das ist eine
wirklich Paul muss man sagen irre
Geschichte der reichste Mann der Welt
der sich jetzt einschaltet in diesen
Krieg mit diesen Vorschlägen ja wie
nennt man das in der Ukraine auf
ja Elon Musk ist nicht nur der reichste
Mann der Welt sondern er hat auch mit am
meisten Twitter Follower 100 Millionen
insgesamt und es ist so dass es in der
Ukraine auch deshalb so für Aufregung
sorgt weil Elon Musk ja eigentlich ein
sehr sehr guten Ruf hatte Patricia und
zwar weil er es geschafft hat mit
starlink insbesondere die Kommunikation
der ukrainischen Soldaten an der Front
sicherzustellen dass Sie Internet haben
dort denn das ist normalerweise nicht
der Fall weil natürlich dort im
Telefonverbindung ausfallen Netze
gekappt sind Elektrizität nicht mehr
funktioniert und deswegen war so ein
bisschen gerade am Anfang des Krieges
der Held hier in der Ukraine der den
Soldaten und auch den Menschen geholfen
hat ich kann mich erinnern an die
Anfangszeit in Kiew als der Boxen
ausgeliefert wurden von Elon Musk damals
auch in der Sorge dass die Russen die
Kommunikation Kappen könnten also
deswegen ist die Aufregung hier
besonders groß insgesamt muss man sagen
es ist wohl die größte Aufregung seit
Beginn des Krieges denn dass ich
selensky einschaltet dass ich ein ja ein
weiterer Präsident einschaltet auf ein
Tweet das ist hier in dieser Debatte so
noch nicht vorgekommen ich glaube das
Gefühl der Ukrainer bringt am besten
wohl der noch Botschafter in Deutschland
auf den Punkt anderen manik der auf Elon
Musk geantwortet hat [__] off denn die
Ukraine haben hier momentan größere
Probleme und beschäftigen sich neben der
Frage mit der Front auch mit der
zunehmenden nuklearen Drohung Patricia
wir haben in der Nacht Berichte von der
Times london gehört gelesen dass diese
dieser Einsatz wahrscheinlicher werden
könnte da es von einem Zug die Rede von
einem sogenannten atomzug der in
Bewegung gesetzt werden sei da ging es
sozusagen nicht um einen akuten Fall
sondern um Training so wird das dort
beschrieben also es könnte ein Test sein
der dort in Gang gesetzt wird aber das
beunruhigt hier natürlich die Menschen
und gleichzeitig sehen wir auf der
anderen Seite ja Propaganda Parolen aus
dem Kreml insbesondere auch von
Tschetschenen Anführer kadirov der jetzt
gesagt hat dass er seine Kinder selbst
in den Krieg schicken will also wir
sehen ist eskaliert hier rhetorisch auf
allen Ebenen
vielen herzlichen Dank für deine
Informationen an diesem Morgen
[Musik]